hello and welcome to math simplified in
this video we will talk about the
polymerase chain reaction in simple
words polymerase chain reaction or PCR
is a technique that is used to make
several copies of a small fragment of
DNA or RNA if you understand the meaning
of the words in PCR we can better tell
about this process from its name itself
PCR is made up of two words polymerase
and chain reaction polymerase means an
enzyme that makes polymers of any other
molecule which in this technique is the
DNA chain reaction is a type of chemical
reaction which progresses in an
exponential way or in simple terms if
the first reaction produces two
molecules the second reaction will make
four and the third will make sixteen
copies and then 32 64 128 512 copies and
so on so in a matter of just a few
hundred reactions we can produce
billions of copies of a single fragment
of DNA before progressing further make
sure to watch the video on structure of
DNA and DNA replication on our channel
for a better understanding of this topic
as many of the terms that we will use in
this video have been discussed in those
topics also I am so excited to share
with you that we have launched our new
t-shirt store on T spring comm featuring
cool tees that medical students and
professionals can relate to we are still
adding more designs on our store support
mat simplified by checking us out on T
spring the next question you would ask
is why would we want to make a billion
copies of a region of DNA
well PCR has thousands of users like in
diagnosing infections and infectious
diseases for example it is used to
diagnose infections by viruses we take
blood of a patient that has been
infected by the virus and then we
amplify the DNA of the virus so that we
are able to study which type of virus it
is and its properties similarly PCR has
been used in hundreds of other fields
like crime investigations genetic
research molecular biology etc
now let's first talk about what are the
things that we need to perform PCR and
then we will discuss how this process
happens the most commonly used equipment
in PCR is the thermal cycler also known
as the PCR machine inside the PCR
machine we have these small tubes in
which all the chemicals are inserted and
the reaction takes place now let's look
at the stuff that we put inside these
tubes that makes this reaction possible
the key ingredients of a PCR reaction
are tagged polymerase primers DNA
templates and the nucleotides
TAC polymerase is a type of DNA
polymerase and like DNA replication in
any organism PCR requires a DNA
polymerase enzyme that makes new strands
of DNA using existing strands as
templates
the DNA polymerase typically used in PCR
is called dark polymerase after the
heat-tolerant bacteria from which was
isolated named thermos aquaticus this
material lives in hot springs and it's
DNA polymerase is very heat stable and
it is most active around 70 degrees this
heat stability is ideal as high
temperatures are needed for this
reaction the second important thing that
we need to perform PCR are the primers
if you have watched the videos on DNA
replication you know that DNA polymerase
needs primers to start the reaction as
the polymerase cannot initiate this
reaction but can only propagate it PCR
primers are short sequences of
nucleotides usually around 20
nucleotides in length primers provide a
starting point for DNA synthesis primers
are also important as they help to
select the exact portion of DNA that
will be amplified and we use to such
primers in each PCR reaction and they
are designed so that they answer late
the target region of the DNA to be
copied DNA template is the segment of
original DNA which we want to amplify
and nucleotides as we already know are
the basic building blocks used for DNA
synthesis
now we will discuss about the process of
PCR PCR involves three simple steps
denaturation annealing and extension
in the first step of polymerase chain
reaction we raise the temperature of the
machine to 96 degree Celsius this is
done to denature or separate the two
strands of DNA so as a result of this
step we get two separate strands of DNA
the next step of PCR is known as
annealing before getting into the
details do you know the meaning of the
word annealing basically this word was
used in the metal industry where they
heat a certain metal to a higher
temperature and then cool it this
process is called annealing which is
basically done to remove the internal
defects from the metal same is the case
here in PCR where we first raise the
temperature of the machine to 72 degrees
for this step one that is denaturation
and then we cool the temperature to 55
degrees so that the primers in the PCR
tube can bind to their target sequence
on the single-stranded DNA now let me
explain the concept of annealing with a
real-world example suppose a patient
comes to you and you suspect an HIV
infection we take the blood sample of
the patient and perform PCR on it the
blood of the patient contains the virus
and in the virus is its genetic material
the DNA so our aim here is to confirm
whether the patient has the infection or
not but the DNA of the virus in our
sample is a very little quantity so you
can say that we need to amplify the DNA
of the virus to detect it so we perform
the first step of PCR that is
denaturation to separate the two strands
of the DNA this is the denatured DNA of
the virus in our sample and in green we
have a specific sequence or gene that we
have decided to amplify and detect later
next comes annealing and the role of
primers we will use two primers which
are basically used to mark the specific
area of the DNA that we want to amplify
the primers have the sequence that
matches the sequence which is present at
the starting point of the target region
of these two strands of DNA the primers
bind to the template DNA by
complementary base pairing in this way
we are able to select a particular
region of the DNA that we want to
amplify so this was annealing next comes
the third step known as extension for
this we also require free
Kyodai it's in these des tubes which
will be basically used to make the new
DNA again we have a detailed video about
the structure of nucleotides on our
channel and link is in the description
for extension we increase the
temperature again to 72 degrees so that
the tag polymerase extends the primers
synthesizing new strands of DNA here you
can see the tag polymerase adding new
nucleotides to the short sequence of the
primer to form new strands of DNA which
is complementary to the original strand
these ingredients are assembled in a
tube along with cofactors needed by the
enzyme and are put through repeated
cycles of heating and cooling that
allows new DNA to be synthesized so what
was the result of this single cycle of
heating and cooling and then heating
again you can see that from one DNA
fragment we got two new double stranded
DNA s one is the original parent DNA and
the other one is a new DNA formed by the
TAC polymerase these steps are repeated
again and this is what that makes the
PCR a chain reaction basically the
products of the first reaction are used
as the substrates for the next reaction
now when we cool down the temperature to
55 degrees for annealing we will get
four single-stranded DNA s now the TAC
polymerase comes in for extension and
this time it leads to synthesis of four
new single stranded DNA s because the
substrates for the enzyme are also
double now so from the second cycle of
the PCR we get one two three four five
six seven and eight new strands of DNA
these steps are repeated again and again
and this is what that makes the PCR a
chain reaction to summarize basically
the products of the first reaction are
used as the substrate for the next
reaction which means that if in the
first reaction we got to DNA out of one
in the second reaction we will get four
DNA's out of two and in the third
reaction we will get sixteen out of four
and similarly by a few hundred reactions
we are able to get billions of copies of
the same fragment of T
this is repeated 25 to 30 times in a
typical PCR reaction not hundred times
which takes two to four R's depending
upon the length of the DNA region being
copied due to the exponential nature of
the change reaction we are able to
produce billions of copies of DNA
fragment from only a single copy of the
fragment after this the temperature is
again lowered to 15 degrees so that the
products of the reaction can be stored
to check whether the PCR has generated
the correct products we use a technique
known as agarose gel electrophoresis
which is a topic for another video so
this is how the process of PCR takes
place in the end I would like to say
that PCR is an amazing technique that
has revolutionized the field of
diagnosis and research one of the most
frequent questions that I get asked here
on YouTube is how to remember what you
study I agree that biology and medicine
involve remembering a lot of factual
information and one of the things that
helped me immensely during Medical
College but flashcards that's why med
simplified has teamed up with Quizlet to
release a brand new collection of
flashcards on biology and medicine
Quizlet is a new online learning
platform where you can study easy to
remember flashcards by me and thousands
of other teachers worldwide all my
simplified flashcards are easy to
understand and contain a lot of images
that help you to remember difficult
topics easily
what makes Quizlet great is that you can
use it on Android or iOS anywhere you
want which makes it super helpful to
revise and remember a lot of volatile
topics right before an exam become a
math simplified member on patreon.com to
unlock all the flashcards from our
videos and also unlock some cool patreon
only member content like exclusive
discounts on meth simplified merchandise
choosing the topic for the next video
and early notifications and behind the
scenes of these videos thank you so much
for watching guys follow us on Facebook
and Instagram for more cool stuff see
you in the next video